what's up everyone this is Anthony
papiano most of you know me as pump
you're listening to off the chain
simply the best podcasting crypto let's
kick this thing off
[Music]
the following episode is part of the
off-the-chain automation series
sponsored by iota the goal of this
special series is to explore the
intersection of distributed ledger
technology and automation specifically
around digital currencies digital
wallets and machine-to-machine
transactions my core belief is that
every stock bond currency and commodity
will eventually be digitized and
distributed ledger technology will
empower the full potential of automation
to be realized
iota is the sponsor of the automation
series their mission is to support the
research and development of new
distributed ledger technologies
including IOT tangle the iota foundation
encourages the education and adoption of
distributed ledger technologies through
the creation of ecosystems and the
standardization of these new protocols
you can find out more about the
automation series and iota in the show
notes
Catherine Coley is the CEO of finance us
in this conversation we discussed her
background how she discovered Bitcoin
and crypto currencies what led her to
take the job at finance and some of the
feature requests like interest accounts
derivatives and mobile apps that may be
coming to buy Nance in the future I
really enjoyed this conversation and I
hope you do as well Anthony pomp lion-o
is a partner at Morgan Creek digital all
opinions expressed by pomp or his guests
on this podcast are solely their
opinions and do not reflect the opinions
of Morgan Creek digital or Morgan Creek
Capital Management you should not treat
any opinion expressed by pomp as a
specific inducement to make a particular
investment or follow a particular
strategy but only as an expression of
his opinion this podcast is for
informational purposes only all right
guys bang-bang special episode alert I
don't even know if that's a thing but
we're gonna start that I have Katherine
here super excited to have this
conversation I've actually known her for
maybe a year so pre getting the job at
by Nance
so one congratulations on that thank you
so much extremely excited before we get
into all the fun stuff and the over 200
questions that I got on Twitter about
what to ask you which we will not cover
all of them let's go through your
background and of what you did pre
Ripoll pre by Nancy etc sure sure so my
my story or my journey starts a little
bit earlier than most even cypherpunks
shockingly when I was about 8 years old
my family went to Disney World quite a
lot I grew up in Orlando Florida and
every Sunday we would go to Epcot every
Sunday every Sunday there were good
deals back in the 90s where with Florida
citizens would get free tickets so we'd
go to Epcot about every Sunday and I go
to Morocco I go to Japan I go to Canada
France all in an afternoon really
painless struggle free a were able to
experience the world and I I kind of
thought that's how the world worked and
then I was proven really really harshly
wrong when I decided to move outside of
the US and so that kind of tipped off my
love of global markets and understanding
how the world wasn't efficient and we
could make it more efficient and so I
kind of kept on this journey for
learning how I could make that a better
make it a small world after all
so I leptin to foreign exchange trading
in Morgan Stanley in Hong Kong right
after college experiencing some of the
least liquid markets out there I was
trading all the onshore Asian currencies
so you think about the small ones
Indonesia and Malaysia Pakistanis and
and so just really experiencing how
difficult those markets were super
nuanced very tricky and then moved with
Morgan Stanley on to London to see some
of the deepest pockets of liquidity so
you've got hold on before you get to
London all right explain currency
trading in Asia because I think a lot of
people here that somebody had that as an
experience in their career but they
don't actually know what that means it
kind of like what the day-to-day is yeah
your day-to-day is downloading the
entire news of the world and then
realizing how it's going to affect the
prices of your one country's currency
against another and then you're handling
that with the largest money managers of
the world so
any call at 3:00 a.m. on a Monday
morning when the Wellington open would
happen you'd be waiting on the phone and
reaching out to people about 250 clients
or so and they could call up any time
and say you know you want to buy two
yards of dollar-yen which is two billion
dollars of dollar yen and you'd have to
work their order through the liquidity
at that time so you couldn't just get a
price off the hand there you'd have to
you know manage the order make sure that
was going through smoothly deal with the
fact that they were probably unhappy
they were moving the market or trying
not to move the market and constantly
try and evaluate where there was value
left in the market for you to go after
so I covered kind of global hedge funds
and then traded the onshore pair so
you're trying to get all of your orders
through before market closes which
onshore markets have closes the rest of
FX is kind of a 24:5 market and so that
was just a full adrenaline rush standing
up shouting you know buy sell that kind
of wolf of Wall Street style but in Asia
you're doing it with a much smaller team
with much trickier markets and just a
ton of responsibility early on so I
really thoroughly enjoyed it got it and
so when you go to London what was the
role there
yeah London was covering global hedge
funds really bringing my expertise from
Asia into the European market so we were
at the time China puts were a very
popular thing that was the idea of
betting on China blowing up and so you
were protecting your risk either to the
equities market or to another exposure
that you may have had by buying a
protection on the price of dollar CNH or
CNY going higher so the numbers that
we're seeing now like I think remedies
now at 714 are strike prices which were
where the where the market might have
gone were like 6 so the markets blown up
since so it's it's rewarding to know
that a lot of the guys I helped get into
those trades it was it was a worthwhile
endeavor but in London we were really
just focused on educating them on what
Asia was like and seeing if they had
appetite for engaging in that type of
investing in those markets and what
investors would that be we say hedge
hunter these really large well-known
hedge funds with a more small
mom-and-pop you know two three-person
operations you know I had this kind of
unusual ability to be the outside
American in these different markets and
then cover us groups so you think about
your hedge funds in New York and
Connecticut even California I was able
to be there kind of liaison
correspondent on the ground telling them
what was happening even if they had
never been to Asia or London at that
time most folks had though so you think
about average AUM or assets under
management and that one of the funds I
was managing would be around like 14 to
16 billion it's a very large yeah
and the average size of trades kind of a
small day trade one-off would be 300
million large day would be you know
anywhere between two and three four
billion so a lot a lot larger size
tickets you see in the FX world then
crypto first two to three billion is
like 1/2 percent of the entire yeah good
ok and so once the first time that you
hear about Bitcoin cryptocurrencies
blockchain etc yeah so because I was in
the FX markets and they were moving me
to another country I had to personally
move my Hong Kong dollar and there I was
you know 24 trying to figure out if I
was gonna pay HSBC my competitor 8% of
my hard-earned lady salary and I really
just didn't want to do that so I looked
into Bitcoin back in the day was Arthur
was beginning his early love affair with
Bitcoin and so kind of dug into it and
some of the some of the inefficiencies
didn't really work for me I don't know
if I wanted to pay that much to take
that transaction on a lot of my hedge
funds had tinkered in it in 2013 and
then got doxxed and so that was
unfortunate but it was still kind of
learning how what would be the best way
to get money across the world in the
fastest way without me losing actual
value and so that's when I looked in the
crypto and kind of
kept my eye on all the processes of how
Bitcoin was working what was the pricing
like was this liquid in Hong Kong dollar
which not a lot of exchanges are live in
Hong Kong dollar on ramps and then kind
of had to do the same thing when I moved
from London to the US again and so
constantly was looking for the best
means of moving money around the world
for sure and Bitcoin is a natural I
think tangentially related asset for
currency traders right it is a currency
has a liquid market
I give such credit to people that come
into Bitcoin without having any foreign
exchange experience because to me it's
just an obvious you know I can put this
asset class and move it just the same
way I've moved other things my
understanding of you know how they can
order book is is the same that I would
be using for understanding markets and
cryptocurrencies the ability to know
just etiquette around buying and selling
on an OTC side and then understanding
managing your own risk those are all
things that I natively learned in
foreign exchange so kudos to people that
are trapped translating other jobs into
this and being able to understand the
dynamics of the market it took me about
five years and a lot of hard hours in
order to just get a good sense of of
things but I think I think the biggest
lesson we can always learn as the market
owes us nothing for sure and so when you
move to the US what was the job yeah so
I moved to the US well pre brexit Morgan
Stanley was kind of getting a little
worried about the fact that they had
some expats on the other side of the
pond and so picking up from brexit
realizing I could potentially be left
homeless and in London without a job
moved over to San Francisco mostly on a
whim I I went to a wedding and it was
lovely out there and I said you know
this weather is perfect and I went to LA
and LA the weather was dismal that week
for some reason and say Oh God because
San Francisco wins and I felt that there
was a level of folks there that would
intellectually stimulate me for enough
for me to realize that I could translate
my job into the tech world I wanted to
be as adaptable to the next generation
of careers as possible and
that certainly felt a little dinosaur at
that time we were automating as much as
we could so I like to make my job
redundant as I go on in life because I
think that means we're progressing and
so I began looking at different tech
companies different FinTech and I kept
finding myself worried about their FX
exposure at the end of the day which I
was like you know you're addicted when
you're worried about you know some
company's exposure to India or some
company's exposure to China and how are
they balancing that and so for the
longest time I'd had an alert on a
ripple for on LinkedIn because I knew
that their XRP moved significantly
cheaper than Bitcoin and if they were
ever going to open up looking for
someone to expand the Hong Kong market
that was my ticket out to get my money
way out of the Hong Kong market so
fortunately one day after a year and a
half of this LinkedIn alert something
popped up that fit my expertise and so I
jumped on that one got it before we get
into Ripple
San Francisco we got to talk about yeah
the wedding you went to was in San
Francisco it was in San Francisco it was
one of my best friends from Carolina we
actually lived in China together so she
had had kind of a global experience and
excitement and it ended up that about
fourteen of my friends from my Hong Kong
Shanghai days are relocated to San
Francisco so it's a you know maybe it's
the easy transition back into the
American life or maybe they just have
really good dim sum I laughed because
San Francisco is the tale of two cities
for sure where you get probably the area
where your friend got married which is
nice and beautiful and they get the
photos and and this great experience and
then if you went to Market Street area
you might have stepped in some human
feces it's a tough city for sure
and so many people say like why would
you you know you know the city shuts
down at 9:00 p.m. et cetera
I mean Hong Kong was a seven it was like
thirty six seven type of city like it
was you were out running hard working
hard playing hard and so for me to be
able to really focus on whatever work I
was going to be doing I didn't get the
FOMO I was missing out on things and I
could
relax go you know hike swim across the
river play golf you name it in
California pretty easily without the
temptations of New York City missing
something do you railing my career
success for sure and so what role you
take a triple
so what ripple I started off as their
head of investor relations actually
which was a total switch for me having
been mostly driving markets and dealing
with direct customers transaction size
and I kind of over the course of a
couple months said yeah you know we're
not a public company and at the time we
were not fund raising so I said can I
can I be on the markets team like a
connect it's hard for me to turn that
off I'm constantly thinking about it I
know the guys that would be having an
appetite for this I naturally speak
their language kind of put me in the
game coach
and so I I jumped over to the XRP
markets team to run the institutional
liquidity okay and so let's start with
the Investor Relations this is mainly a
role where you're interfacing with the
investors in the private software
company Ripple not X right right correct
yeah I was working mostly with the
financial community a lot up here a lot
in California just referencing it as if
it was a like an on deal Roadshow
teaching them about a tech company
called ripple got it and so when you
jump over to the capital markets team or
the local institutional liquidity
describe a little bit more like what the
goal of that team would be yeah so we
were a scrappy team that was really our
purpose was to make X RP as liquid as
possible one of the things in order for
it to work through the system was that
it would be the conduit between
transactions around the world and if you
looked at FX being that conduit around
the worlds that average volume a day was
like five to six trillion so if we were
gonna be able to make transactions of
that quality go through you would need
to have a much more liquid mechanism so
that's where you can either see the
price rising to accommodate for the
volume necessary or you can see the
liquidity increasing for volume
necessary to handle got it and so as you
think through those mechanisms right I
think one of the big questions that
a lot of folks have just across Bitcoin
crypto etc is how much of the occult
market making or liquidity / providing
is done by teams themselves versus by
exchanges versus by like institutional
type clients partners market
participants etc but just you know I
kind of think of it as three buckets
right so it's the teams themselves in
some cases do market making liquidity
sometimes it's the actual exchanges and
kind of like off-balance sheet type
stuff and sometimes it's external third
parties are more like funds that are set
up to do this stuff yeah we break it
down to kind of if you it's similar to
that if you've got one structure being
infrastructure so that's like your
exchanges your OTC desks kind of that
core venue that you're gonna be trading
on and then you've got the speculators
which can be anything from you know a
retail day trader all the way through to
you know significant endowment or a fund
and then you've kind of got the the
third leg that doesn't really exist yet
and that's corporate flow which is a
significant reason why the FX markets
move you've watched that you've got that
consistent need for a company in one
area to make a transaction repeatedly
based on their needs from a corporate
perspective so you think about Toyota
and their dollar yen they have to
repatriate all of their revenues from
overseas every quarter or every year in
order to clean up their balance sheet
and prepare for a fiscal year ahead
so those flows don't exist yet in the
crypto markets but we're working on and
so that's one of the things where if you
have that consistent flow then the
speculators will be able to take
advantage of those different seasonality
of corporate flows but you also just
always have momentum in the market
taking place so I think that's one of
the factors that ripple is really
working on was being able to provide a
mechanism to which corporate flows would
be consistent so you'd have people using
the mechanism of XRP in order to send
flows from one country to another at a
consistent pace or at least a repeatable
one
then the speculation or that arm would
be able to go as they please but that
way you'd always have kind of two-sided
markets naturally got it all right so
you're doing this for year and a half
two years two years that ripple and all
of a sudden there's this announcement
that's right that you're gonna become
the CEO of is it finance America or
finance us finance us our twitter
handles finance America okay will a be
test what is like if it's on the
internet it's true so we have holiday
either one let's start with what was
your first in time that you heard about
by Nance your first impression you know
before you met anyone on the team etc
what was kind of your take sitting in
the seat at a ripple of Finance yeah so
I mean we were working with all the
exchanges possible in order to see if X
nor P could be listed on those the
increasing amount of access liquidity is
you can kind of think of it in two ways
one of them is access to market the
other one is depth of the market so
access would be as many venues as
possible listing or providing quotes of
your your pair and so we've been working
were working with all the exchanges and
then personally had been trying to
interface with all of them to understand
and there was something that I kind of
respected about by Nance having popped
up right before kind of the the major
hype we both kind of started our crypto
storyline at around the same time summer
2017 and so just seeing how nimble they
worked and how accommodating they were
for the appetite of the market during
this kind of hype cycle initially or one
of many that had happened I just had a
huge respect for them and so about a
year ago I've met we gel on a bus in
Singapore and I sat down next to this
guy and just kind of as I who he is I
had no idea who as you do kind of or as
I do is sit down and like tell me about
yourself hi how are you I'm Kohli like
what's going on and he ended up being
the CFO of Finance he's incredibly kind
insanely kind like you would never think
that this is the guy who's who's making
this whole thing run
alongside and the two of us hit it off
and he was like wait how do you know
these guys I'm like they were my interns
I'm Morgan Stanley and he's like what
this doesn't make like what are you
doing knowing our region our market like
how does how does this make make sense
so really enjoyed each other's company
and kind of kept in touch on checking in
on the market what made sense what
didn't what was the path that was
happening with XRP you know where was my
Nance headed etc and really wanted to
make something work between the two of
us and in terms of we both appreciated
our work styles so it's out six months
ago or the beginning of January or so I
kind of got the tap on the shoulder that
said we'd we'd like what you do and we'd
like to go to America with you mm-hmm
and it kinda was floored and then said
like bring it on like hold on before we
get into the America plans yeah once
first time you meet cz it's easy I'm
same time so we got off the bus he was
like I gotta introduce you to a couple
people and so he introduced me to see
Helen hi who runs Sonia's charity
foundation you know a kind of a great
group of them that were there at the
Cumberland summit and Singapore last
year John and and Suzy was just you know
so well-spoken such a such a visionary
very kind of lucid in his his plans
going forward so had a huge amount of
respect David financed Odion I think to
do the financed hoodie I mean it's so
hot in Singapore I'm pretty sure was a
t-shirt they were doing hoodies that
would then one of the questions that I
got over and over again is one when do
the retail investors get by Nancy so
we'll get to that yeah I mean we
designed the u.s. hoodie and it is sharp
and I
I've made a made a couple requests for
some other it's another us swag that I
think I'll get the market excited but at
the same time I'm like yeah do we come
we have a scarf yeah for sure they they
they for the second anniversary they got
us necklaces so that's pretty nice what
what is the initial pitch from cz way
and kind of the finance team in terms of
yeah they want to come to America but
what exactly does that mean for you know
what what is a business that it back in
January is probably what two years old
or so gone from relatively non-existent
in 24 months to hundreds of employees
you know 30 40 different countries
hundreds of millions of dollars if not
more in revenue annie buddha and and
just this massive thing that got created
nowhere and they call you and say hey
were coming to america what's the point
I mean like they didn't have that much
of a vision they were like would you be
our partner in America mm-hmm up to you
mm-hmm you figure out how you want to
you figure out how you want to do it
we've got this technology if there is a
plan to provide access for crypto
markets through by Nance around the
world avoiding the u.s. is an obvious
thing that you cannot say you have
global reach you're leaving out the US
and so I think that was you know a bold
step for them to say let's figure out a
way to do it we'll give it to you if you
can make it work we can make it work if
you can't make it work we now know that
we can't be in the US yep and I said you
know what's a better canary in a coal
mine than to say if I can make this
successful fantastic if I can't
wonderful way to leave the entire
krypter than just true
yep and find a new job yeah yeah for
sure
okay so you started when everything in
the role is CEO finance us yeah CEO
finance us
I run BAM trading services which is the
private company that I'm responsible for
we do business as finance us
significantly more catchy than BAM
trading services so kind of
transitioning they're just saying
finance us and so I started in June I
had a you know my time off in between
ripple and I know I flew down from
consensus
you have Monday my birthday and then
Tuesday on the job also it was a great
gift buckle up yeah alright and so as
you get started what you in June what's
your first impression of Finance and
kind of how they operate in this super
decentralized fast-growing company yeah
I had always for some reason struggled
when I was even at Morgan Stanley that
the pace to which I wanted to operate
was always held back and the ideas that
I wanted to execute on were always
questioned and that's just part of
growing up you are of course going to be
tempered by Authority what when I came
to over to buy Nance the ability to
provide an idea and then route the
execution of it and do it was applauded
so it gets you to really find a problem
create a solution execute it put it in
production independently which is unlike
any other company I've worked for
normally it's you know paralysis by
committee or emails on emails on emails
and so this was just a wonderful pace to
say alright I'm gonna be running the
u.s. so I'm gonna need this this this
I'm gonna go after that it puts a lot of
the responsibility on your shoulders and
you can't just say you're gonna build a
team and then wait for someone to build
it for you you kind of have to then
begin the grassroots of recruiting
people and going through that process
and writing up your offer letters to
them I mean they're the whole
soup-to-nuts kind of version is all
yours but that's amazing the runway is
there so I really appreciate that and
still to this day I'm so grateful for
the idea that that's the culture that I
get to kind of bring over for sure and
let's go through kind of an overview of
where you guys are today with finance us
kind of what are the product offerings
and what are the services that if I'm a
user or trader here in the US I want to
go in create an account what's available
- yeah so Finance u.s. is a digital
asset marketplace we get a license the
cutting edge technology of by Nance for
the matching edge
for the wallet software a lot of the key
features that they've already built out
I'm able to license and bring to us
users so I think about it in the ways of
what do American users want what have
they been missing in the market and what
can we really adapt for the regulations
that we have in place here and for the
the gray areas as well so we launched on
Tuesday of last week going alive with
trading and we have several pairs and
then the one of the best parts about how
we're rolling out is this two-way
conversation with our users and there
was a great demand for Bitcoin pairs and
so then 24 hours later we launched with
a couple Bitcoin pairs as well and so we
have a list of 30 tokens that we are
exploring and we've already launched in
about twelve of those and so we'll be
continuing to provide variety to the
market as well as lowering the hurdles
in order to understand this space all
right so before we jump really really
deep down into the products and
offerings how do you look at Finance and
what you're bringing to the market as
kind of a competitive landscape in the
United States right cuz I think the
international markets are very different
than the United States markets or I
guess the United States market and then
here in the US I think that there's a
number of well-known brands but they all
offer different things right and some of
them have gone really deep in the US
lots of different options some have said
we're gonna go deep in the US with very
little trading options and everything in
between that so kind of how do you see
that competitive landscape compared to
what you're trying to do yeah I come
from a insane position right now of I
have to say privilege I'm able to watch
several of the top US peers having spent
six seven years already figuring out the
recipe for for success for them so I'm
able to enter the market having that
awareness and then being able to modify
on it quickly with a substantial brand
behind
and great technology that the rest of
the world sees is a good fit so coming
coming into the USA I have a huge
advantage for that but also
significantly still the underdog because
we are so late to the game you can call
it and so I think there's a couple of
aspects that we really want to round out
that I think the crypto community has
almost began to silo itself in some
respects so the idea that the u.s. is
saturated why would I enter it it's so
many so many other peers in that space I
think we still have a lot more in order
to get crypto to be an everyday thing
for the everyday user the intimidation
level of Kryptos kind of gone back up so
that's one of the things that I want to
make sure we can bring that back down
and lower the hurdles to entry whether
that is cost whether that is
understanding let's educate not
intimidate and begin to provide an
offering that people really want they've
had enough time to figure out what works
in terms of a product side and know what
they really care for and we can build
that for them mm-hmm and how do you
leverage the relationship with I'll call
it by Nance global as an advantage
versus maybe other folks who don't have
that kind of relationship or that
backing him if you will yeah it's as if
I kind of put it in a scenario of an
older brother or older sister they
forged the way they've done things in a
fantastic route and I get a draft behind
that momentum but I am my own human so
like much like my older sister like she
did a great job making my reputation
seem great I got the benefit of the
doubt when I walked in the room because
I looked just like her but I was
definitely the remix version of her and
could stand on my own and and create my
own path so I think that's what we're
kind of looking for is the ability to
realize that by Nance has been adopted
by a great great number of people and
has educated the markets in a way that
people are hungry for all of that
information they're able to provide and
each product they roll out which they
roll out all the time
enhances the experience that the global
community has and so we are going to be
able to spin up as quickly as possible
on those different products and features
for sure and then last question before
we really go into binding us is how do
you look at exchanges both yours and
others in the US as kind of the role of
soliciting these US based institutions
rights whether they're financial kind of
Wall Street type institutions like the
major banks etc or they're more like
institutions that I deal with on a daily
basis which are the pensions the
endowments the foundations etc how do
you see the exchanges that are very
crypto specific right so it's not Nasdaq
it's not New York Stock Exchange this is
you know finance coinbase Gemini Kraken
etc what's their role in soliciting that
institutional interest and participation
yeah I mean first starters it's very
unusual that you would type into your
browser or something that would give you
access to financial instruments so in
most scenarios you've got a banks GUI or
system that you've downloaded to your
desktop and it takes up real estate on
one of your sell side analysts or buy
side analysts of platforms so a very
closed loop and normally in financial
infrastructure for having that single
dealer platform or even an aggregator
for pricing so the ability for crypto
exchanges to bring that to the
mainstream through just a simple website
is a remarkable innovation on how you
can access financial products the other
side of it I see is infrastructure or
crucial elements of the exchanges is it
is it is providing that ability to go
and buy and sell digital assets and then
begin to explore rolling out different
products to those those users so without
it you would have you know a combination
of peer-to-peer or OTC and I think both
of those elements can also be wrapped up
into the exchange model it's just an
element of you know trying to go after
one thing one at a time versus being one
for all and having a having a little bit
of a hard time being able to handle that
much
for sure well in you bring up a great
point around the assets are different
some of the business models are a little
different some of the user experiences
are different and so I think if you look
across the ecosystem both domestically
internationally for the United States
people kind of it's like a buffet right
and they really do choose you know what
this is one of them I kind of combined
with what user experience with what
assets with you know what jurisdictions
and and you get these really unique
offerings and I think that answers the
question of like why are there so many
because it's different things for
different people yeah I mean if you
think about like bestbuy.com
selling only electronics that made sense
there you go that was your marketplace
for electronics and then Amazon comes
around and you can buy you know eggs
salad dressing socks and electronics and
you're kind of like okay there's there's
ability to have one marketplace with
multiple offerings now and people are
not as afraid of that they don't need to
go to a specialized store they don't
need to go to a a specific dealer for it
they can go you know to it to a broader
marketplace for sure
so I cheated and I against you oh I
pulled Twitter for a bunch of questions
I told him that we were gonna do this
and frankly they came up with a lot of
much better questions that I would have
come up with and a lot of also much more
stupid questions that would have come up
with so I'm all eager to focus on the
good ones the good stupid ones wrong
yeah
well the the stupid ones are maybe both
throw one or two those in at the end but
in terms of the good ones there's a lot
of questions probably almost 25% of the
questions center around two ideas one is
and they're they touch on regulation but
they're one Y only available in certain
states to begin with and kind of what
does that look like going forward and
then to is what is the framework you use
to evaluate tokens or assets kind of
what is the the kind of path forward
there so let's start with first the
states so you guys are in how many
states today what's kind of keeping you
from going to all 50 and kind of how do
you think about that evolving over time
yeah there's nothing more frustrating
than realizing that you cannot deliver
to your home and to your university town
the product that you've built and worked
so hard on so I feel your frustration I
call it the hurricane corridor because
it's the Florida Georgia North Carolina
Louisiana Alabama Texas crowd New York
of course as well we're not able to
serve among a few others so they're
about 13 States we were yet to have a
licensing for and that's the real reason
I'm about 37 state about 37 states yet
we just math on my part could work and
then we just opened up for Puerto Rico
as well so is that ever gonna become a
state I feel like I feel like we should
just make a decision here they're humans
they're the president's trying to buy
other land what he said about the humans
but again Puerto Rico in as a state I
feel like they might get a little bit
more aid and might actually you know
actually treat them better if I feels
the state well they have access to
finance us so we treat them and we treat
them as a great community for for crypto
and so that you know the reason behind
the rolling out gradually rather than
doing it with all 50 or I think it's
only 49 Hawaii is a pretty tough one
regulation wise is we wanted to get to
market quickly there's not a reason for
us to wait on the sidelines until we had
all of our licenses when we could start
providing liquidity to you this is all
money transmitter license money
transmitter license by state by state
and in its long process but with that
it's one that should be you know pretty
methodical we've seen several other
groups be able to do it go through
you've seen most when people say oh I'm
able to do this on this exchange it's
because they've had either seven years
advanced notice if in getting their
licenses in advance or you know we're
grandfathered into to a lot of these
things what goes into applying for and
ultimately getting approved from money
transmitter license at the state level
like I think a lot of you have heard
that but they don't know what exactly
that right a lot of it is just
clarifying with the state your nature of
your business understanding your
financials understanding what you intend
to do and what your customer
interactions going to be like so really
just sharing our story and our kind of
proof of what we're doing to those
states state by state so a lot of
paperwork a lot of paperwork so we you
know we've got a great team that's
already done this before for other
companies so it shouldn't be a problem
but do do appreciate your patience
it a lot of a instead of wind moon it's
like wind Texas and he was actually
Texas and for over the to stay down well
you think about it they've got a lot of
a lot of great people yeah the the the
other part of this question was around
the assets and the framework that you
use and and I'm guessing and correct me
if I'm wrong there's probably two
aspects of this so there's assets that
finance us would like to list right in
terms of they meet some kind of quality
threshold and maybe you can kind of
shine light on that but then also
there's the regulatory you know
component of there's probably things you
want to listen and you don't want to
list there so kind of what is that
process how do you vet these and then
how do you also make a decision as to
what gets listen to what doesn't yeah I
mean you have to kind of think about the
advantage for an exchange could be
around so many things I've done the
research of the front pages of all these
exchanges and they have their tag lines
of you know longest standing exchange
our longest most trusted easy to use at
your fingertips all those are qualities
that we were trying to figure out what's
what's our advantage here and a for us
variety is one thing that has been a
successful model of allowing anyone to
find what really gets in understanding
crypto it might not necessarily be
Bitcoin for me it wasn't I've grown to
learn that you know the beauty of it
eventually but that's also because the
price of transacting in Bitcoin has come
down substantially so it fit more into
my understanding of how the world should
work but we don't really want to
discriminate against that for the
everyday user to find what makes them
clinton what makes it click so we've
established the digital asset risk
assessment framework which really walks
through each pair into an understanding
of is it proper and fit for us users so
breaking down
you know key components within the
regulation framework that we've received
although it's a very kind of gray area
our to our best ability to assess
whether this is a viable offering for
the market and I've seen just recently
today there's been kind of a consortium
put together to establish a rating
system as well and we would see fit to
compare ours as well as be part of
theirs I think this is one of the things
where collective forces can be good but
also if it is our ability to stand up
and say us users do deserve this variety
in the market let us see and push that
that boundary as as much as we can so in
that process like what are some of the
things that would come into
consideration is that things that are
maybe I'll break it into buckets of like
the structure of of the asset is it the
way that it was brought to market is it
kind of the the state that it is and
today is it all of those things some of
those things like how do you yeah you
think you kind of started one through
three and there's probably a you know
handful more of the criteria that we go
through pretty good guesses I should be
on the legal team at Finance us you know
I'm an illegal team you wouldn't make it
through that framework but the the
breakdown is really the state to which
the coin or token came into the market
the team itself behind it whether they
have a long-term vision whether this
will be in the markets through
perpetuity whether the mechanism to
which it is operated can sustain that
the liquidity elements in the u.s. some
places have zero liquidity against the
US dollar and maybe you're only traded
through Bitcoin the community behind it
is there a substantial group of active
traders or is this you know one guy in
the corner shouting like please list
this and it's fine if he's going to be
doing serious volume yeah yeah but you
know there's a there's a need for
healthy markets and without that you
create kind of this tail
occurs in the market that might lead for
patchy liquidity or prices the gap and
and that leads to inability to actually
put utility behind these things so
imagine if you were a corporate trying
to transact through a currency and there
was no liquidity and you you gaped in
price from like 6 to 32 you're not going
to come back to that shop and keep keep
them trying to go through that mechanism
so I think a lot of it is how is it used
how can we help projects that need a
venue point to increase liquidity that's
something that's crucial if it's going
to help a project or a purpose kind of
continue in the in the space of digital
assets we want to be the open vendor for
for capturing that got it and so what
would be one or two of the most common
reasons why something would get rejected
from the processor kind of not past oh I
think well one would be false
infrastructure so though they are a
shell there's no one behind it there's
no real thought behind it it was a you
know a color scheme and a four-letter
pair of words so I think that's one
thing we can easily throw out so really
digging under the ground of saying we
just put that in like scam yeah scam
coin but a shell is a nice way to call
it a scam yeah you call it a scam I'll
try and sound a little bit nicer to
those people so I don't get harassed on
Twitter you have to embrace twill get
the Twitter it's always paying attention
all right so that's the states and kind
of the assets in terms of today you
simply offer what I'll just call kind of
sparked a spot market trading right so I
can come in and there's different pairs
that I can trade and there's bid asks
buyer seller off to the races and that's
all it's available today right yeah
you've got your orders you've got an
order book full exchange set up against
USD SDT and Bitcoin on some pairs and so
that Fiat on-ramp is something that
we're really excited to be able to offer
yep and
I believe I remember correctly all
trading is free until November that is
correct
all trading is free until November first
and if you're worried about your state
not being live we will also be looking
into keeping those exciting things for
those states that when they do go live
so you won't be left behind and then
also if you have friends which I think
the big thing about crypto is maybe
we've lost some of our friends so now is
the time to earn them back or work with
them teach them what you've been up to
and why the rabbit-hole is fun to be in
you'll get $15 and so will they
if they both start if you both start
trading so got it that's kind of the the
great plans we've got so far but free
trading is an exciting thing for those
that are looking to figure out how this
works a lot of the earlier on-ramps for
them have been expensive and they didn't
know you know why am i paying such a
percentage on a volatile asset already
I'm afraid of it just get in get get
messy as as negative yielding debt has
become popular in the world will we see
negative exchange fees so I get paid for
trading if you're good you know there's
a there's a world that we are going to
be growing into with the the negative
rate it might be a new norm people might
expect to be paid for things it feels a
little entitled right now but I won't
call the person out by name
there is a ridiculous person on the
internet who continues to argue that
negative yielding debt is not only
normal but makes sense because you
should be paying somebody to take care
of your money and there's no risk in
putting your money in the bank which is
all nothing we won't get into but
somebody needs to explain to this person
about 2008 yeah alright so there was a
whole bunch of questions around what
I'll call product or service offerings
that are potential for an exchange offer
so I'm just gonna run through these feel
free to say yes something you're working
on no you're not or elaborate the first
one which was my favorite one was a robo
advisor I saw that it was that um Tyrone
yeah Ross shout out shout out Tyrone
Ross great idea there's nothing better
than ottoman
what you're doing anyways but I
certainly had to put my kind of thinking
cap on like how would that work okay so
are you are you allocating someone to
then just manage on behalf of you and I
think the ability for finance us to be a
platform that allows for new job
creation and new kind of a modern-day
private wealth manager can't exist so
certainly going down that brokerage
model is something fascinating I've seen
finance comm roll out a broker a partner
platform as well so anything that
finance comm is able to launch I'm able
to license awesome tyrona is no if you
want clarification on that you know
where to find us on Twitter interest
accounts mm-hmm so the idea of having a
savings account that earns yield I think
that's very attractive a lot of things
that I'm doing are earning no yield and
that's a difficult part of dealing in
crypto are dealing in something that
will not return unfortunately my banks
also don't return anything so you know
for being able to provide that is a
really great added added advantage for
derivatives yeah so big bucket but
people also forget that like the
derivatives market in regular FX is
about like three times the spot market
so it is a massive beast if you can get
100x leverage on finance us I wasn't a
no it wasn't a no I've got to do my
homework I've got to talk to so talk to
the right regulators figure out what's
the process it's it's a but it's
something that you guys are at least
interested in if you can figure out the
right way to do it and provide it in a
safe manner definitely you want it
absolutely I mean you think about if any
corporate is gonna be using crypto and
using a mechanism have having a balance
sheet in crypto you're going to need
some form of protection on that so
hedging is a concept that I don't think
crypto has really been a part of because
we've been so speculative one way or the
other but things pretty normal yeah so
hedging is a way to look at derivatives
in a risk management model I think most
people encrypt it to your point they
always ask how high can i yeah okay
so yes if you're using it correctly it
should be used as a hedge market but if
you're looking just for you know
outsized returns risk then yeah so well
we'll try to try to cater to your needs
got it can't let Arthur have all the fun
with his fifty and a hundred X leverage
are there any that you think are shorter
term like it as you guys pushed into
derivatives you would say hey legs like
these are the ones that we would
actually want to go after first or is it
still something where it's more blank
slate and I mean I mean that I like to
zoom out a little bit before we start
getting all hopped up in derivative land
and realized that financial literacy is
not something that is a hundred percent
guaranteed across the United States so
if we are able to provide a way to which
people are now getting smarter about
learning how to manage their money
owning their own lives you know that's a
significant step that I think needs to
happen before we can start dialing up
derivative land you can we can derive we
can dial-up derivative land but you're
really going to be isolating the
exposure to just the crypto elite or the
you know the folks that are already in
the space and I think that's too soon
for us to close the door and already
sound like you know you're the varsity
team so I'm bringing it back we're going
back to the beginning of making sure
that people are aware not intimidated by
it understanding what you know what is
buy what does it sell how does this
market work why are things going up
where I thinks going down while also
educating them we don't have like a dumb
down system it is a still an order book
so you'll see everything that in regular
trader will see got it
making your taxes easier was a huge once
a number of these exchanges have tried
to help in various ways what was kind of
the plan there yeah that's a that's a
u.s. major issue of okay I want to be
doing this but I'm gonna be penalized on
all fronts given the taxes and so that
was a high priority of mine to make sure
that you had a very quick way to
download all of your transactions even
for pattern recognition on your own
front being able to assess your P&L and
I know
that you can dig into your own data a
little bit more was an important thing
so there's super easy ways to download
custom amount of time three months six
months one year a year today custom
dates and that'll allow you to to keep
it taxes a little bit cleaner as well
you know they're a great amount of tax
providers now in crypto and so we'll be
trying to help folks even before October
15th and April 15th get get in the right
direction got it that one is a huge one
because one of the things that people I
don't think realize is when you go and
you sell into some of these order books
it doesn't get executed in one trade and
sometimes it can be two three five ten
twenty trades and each individual one of
those if you do the taxes to the exact
accuracy counts as a taxable event your
little error your accountant will have a
lot of fun with that
yeah the market owes you nothing so you
have to make sure you do taxes right
absolutely
alright the big one mobile app everyone
everyone was talking about this on
Twitter it's coming I think I've heard
yeah I feel like I went to school
without my backpack so there were
definitely getting an app up and look up
and I've been off the ground it was a
case of we wanted to go to market before
we had all of our school supplies that's
okay that's a good thing it's a good
thing you know if I made it through the
first day of school or the first week of
school without my backpack I'm gonna do
okay but no there is going to be an app
we're gonna you know try and except as
well our users are on the go
America is on-the-go mobile saturation
is huge we want to we want to put it at
your fingertips got it iOS and Android
is the plan I think so okay I have both
just making sure this one I did not
understand but USD withdrawals and USD T
trading pairs I'm assuming that those
are either already there or on the way
or they are there yeah so we have all of
our current offerings against US dollar
and USD T and I think we'll probably
hopefully see you know
more crosses coming the way I'm sorry
crosses for that example is just
different pairs of trading got it credit
cards credit cards America runs on
credit most of the time I think it's
great could be a politician ahead some
financial sir if financial services firm
that will definitely donate to your
campaign yeah well it's funny my sister
and I had our career so she works in
corporate credit cards at a large US
bank night I work over on this side but
I embarrass my brother he works at
JPMorgan yeah well she's at City yeah if
you think of all of my tweets now at
wall one of my brother's is sitting at
JPMorgan you can imagine his uh his
buddies they're giving them a hard time
quite often are you the older or younger
I'm the oldest of all of my brothers
that throws a loophole and my theory in
life but two of them are in financial
services and you know they get a good
laugh every now and then they do alright
so credit cards are common to finance us
they're coming one of the tricky parts
is when you said it's coming so if
you're listening sweet and say credit
cards are coming when you when you look
at the credit card industry which people
haven't dug into that as much as they've
dug into understanding proof of work I
think there are huge fees that are not
even driven by the end user or the end
provider so translating a merchant
processing fee of three percent to our
customer when we're providing free
trading still feels pretty gross
so we want to be able to provide access
to these things in a cost-effective way
and currently credit cards are still not
cost-effective so thinking through that
it's something that we want to be very
cautious about but I understand people
want to be able to use their debit and
credit cards so do you think they want
it because of the kind of user
experience we just know they just wanna
be able to go do the same thing that
they do but they want to be able to
spend crypto rather than spend dollars
or do you think it's something else
that's really driving the the interest
there you know sometimes it's it's as
funny as we offer right now ACH and wire
payments and right now you have to
either know your bank login or I know
you're routing the number and your
account number okay sometimes people
don't have that when they're you know on
the road or somewhere else but they will
have their credit card on them
so it's a ability to say I know how to
access my funds through a plastic device
that's on me most of the time verse I
know by heart my banking number but ACH
up to $1,000 is instantaneous delivery
wires you can do up to a significant
amount based on your verification levels
so don't think there's not a way to get
dollars into the system it's just not a
credit card security tokens so these are
for those that are paying attention at
home
essentially assets that represent will
call them digital stocks digital equity
they could be in real estate and
traditional stocks but it looks very
similar to a traditional security but
it's just simply in digitized form again
zoom out start small this is just the
beginning I think we're a little bit
pushing the envelope ahead of our skis
to say we're gonna go down the path of
security offerings when you don't have
ninety five percent of the u.s. using
market in involved and so so baby steps
get them get get more of the world
involved and then we can start providing
those products to the right people but
still zooming out zooming out starting
at the beginning I think there's a lot
of land grab
verse expand upon what we've got got it
are there any products that people did
not speculate on that you're excited
about thinking about or worth mentioning
I mean I've always given wonderful kudos
to finance engineers who came up with
the idea that after you type in your to
FA you don't have to click enter but
that's a very small small thing that no
one notices it is very good when you use
the site where it auto processes after
you filled out beautiful number of
characters beautiful so a couple of the
things we want to really be able to
provide best practices this is not a
easy transition to get into the market
like it is to go from a bus to Andover
so we want to you know equip people with
the right tools that's including
security so learning how to if a works
learning how Google Authenticator work
that's just kind of part of the the
growing up case that you need to have in
order to access digital assets it's
going to help you be smarter about your
decisions and in keeping keeping all of
your items very secure which i think is
first and foremost we can't have
reckless behavior taking place for sure
all right you've been on the job now
three nights 90 days all right three
months so I want really hard-hitting
answers to what is let's start with cz
best attribute worst attribute and
funniest story okay best attribute is
his clarity on a vision that is not in
this decade III think that I agree with
that that's something that if you can
align your personality with where your
soul deserves to be that is the answer
to success and that's something that
I've found day one on the job being able
to completely aligned where I want to
grow where I think I'm suited for the
purpose of and it fits in with C's plans
and so that's something that I really
appreciate him having that's best best
worst no backhanded compliments worst is
like two men still wear fizzle it flop
there's only two people I know that wear
flip-flops on consistent basis Charlie
Shrem and cz and then they celebrate
with each other on the internet whatever
there's a picture of one of them in
flip-flops oh let it slide but like come
on no wood anywhere when he's in the
Bahamas he wore shorts flip-flops and a
bi Nance
I think a collared shirt or a hoodie
yeah you did start the Bermuda shorts
trend so I appreciate him for that all
right
a couple people have been there too I
guess before but yeah thought that'd
probably be my only knock is uh it's a
flip-flops day but he wears it all
around Singapore - oh well I mean you
have - it's really hot there yeah all
right funniest story you have funniest
story you know I'll probably get a
message on this whether I was allowed to
reveal this or not but
we were sitting down for lunch and Tommy
told me yeah they were sitting down for
lunch and somehow got on the
conversation of oldest youngest sibling
debates okay and it's easy and I
immediately realized like this is why we
see so similarly and it's because we're
both younger siblings of an older sister
and therefore there's this unusual and
not not welcomed just organic
competitiveness in the younger sibling
that says we need we need to be here on
this earth to make an impact and
honestly no one no no one in my family
has ever said like I'm not worthy or or
it's it's not the case of what I need to
do I just I feel it in my bones that I
was out always out to serve and be
competitive and that that's kind of
what's easy and I both laughed over that
it it's not because our siblings are
mean to us or anything they're both
super achieving people we just all just
wanted to outdo them who is the one
person that by Nance that you say they
are a unknown rock star and people
should know who they are but they don't
today who's one person who comes like I
would I reveal that now they're come on
no one's allowed to go recruit this
person for at least 24 hours yeah
seriously I'm a huge fan of my legal and
regulatory in the u.s. he was the first
tire I had and we had a wonderful week
in San Francisco kind of going through
the the roadmap of what we needed to get
in place to be operational and we had a
we had a moment where we were both
standing up we by the way our office was
and kind of still is at the time like a
closet sized room with bay area view I
mean a gorgeous window but very much so
we had to open the door because we ran
out of oxygen so we stood there watch
the Sun set and he goes Koli I think I'm
gonna be a part of something
significantly bigger than I imagined and
I said that's my guy like just I really
enjoyed aligning with him his creativity
and resourcefulness on getting things
done he thinks about things so
thoughtfully lawyers and the legal side
don't have it easy
they also serve as advisors to the
maniacs that are sometimes the business
leaders so for every a rational idea
that I might come up with he is a way to
either temper it or provide a viable way
for us to do that and I give him huge
credit Christopher Robin's name I was
waiting for the name there I Oh
Christopher Robins and and he does have
a dog named Winnie so I appreciate that
he lanes n the number of LinkedIn
requests for him just went through the
roof the great guy don't waste his time
though
so sitting here ninety days after you
started what's the one thing that you
did not realize that it surprised you
the most I think it comes from the
excitement of the full process of
getting something launched I'm not a
mother so I don't really know how the
process of motherhood works yet I'm not
a mother either yeah well I probably
most of crypto probably is not a mother
but if you are a mother in crypto shout
out that's awesome but the entire detail
required to have a company up and
running and not only a company but a
viable product and not only a product
but one that goes into a highly
competitive market and is live and the
bugs are working I've I've done customer
support for finance us for the past 72
call it 80 hours you're talking to me
when you put a complaint out there or
there's a support ticket so I've had the
joy of seeing what's what's buggy for a
person and how we can fix it or what is
not an intuitive process that my brain
said clearly steps one through three and
it's really helped us get a sense of
where the product is missing the mark
and we can adjust it immediately so
within just a week of going live we've
fixed and adjusted some so many small
things that I hope will ease the path
for folks to come but I also just enjoy
seeing who our users are getting to know
them a little bit more being being
available to someone that is a
first-time user of frequent user of
crypto I've had so many people say I'm
on you know
six exchanges in the US and you guys are
you know I'm gonna be myself I'm like
why you know tell me
what's what's what's your reason for
adding a new one what's your reason
would you move all your funds over you
know how how was the experience was it
was it was it good until the point where
something didn't work for you and oh
yeah it's super super easy I like that
all right well what are we complaining
about but I've just really enjoyed
meeting our users and being a part of
that experience which you don't always
get when you're a small fry in a big
company for sure
let's do rapid-fire yeah and this thing
most important company in crypto other
than your own
can't say bye Nance global either yeah
probably block works isn't an answer
thanks guys for the podcast thanks for
making a digestible experience for all
users around the world I might say that
I think communication is a huge key if
we're able to break this down for ears
and eyes and make people will be able to
understand it that's a huge step for all
companies going forward it's fair answer
yeah
what is the one regulation you would
change or improve in the United States
if you could wave a magic wand having a
driver's license dedicated to your own
state wait what do you mean like why do
I have to be tied down to my place of
residence I mean I get it this is
opening a can of worms on an identity on
identity and driver's license in a
letter but like how many people drive
these days oh you're saying that you
would change the fact that you have to
have a New York state driver's license
or a California state driver's license
like it's it's a state-by-state
state-by-state thing and it's a driver's
license
like we don't offer uber licenses so are
people driving as much these days are
people what guess the US passport would
serve as like the federal so we allow
that right we allow for passports as
well so that works but it was always a
tricky one for me I think my Florida ID
I did go in the DMV and sit for like
three hours right before I joined
financed us because I think I need a
California ID my personal favorite
a concealed carry permits okay oh gosh
oh no we're going guns so you can get
them in states but they're reciprocated
in States oh and so there's this whole
game for those that have ever looked
they could still carry permits where
Florida is the answer because Florida is
reciprocated in the most states so if
you get a concealed carry permit in
Florida then you can get it in the most
number of states yeah with that one
application but do you think that you
have to go to Florida to get the
concealed carry permit
probably not you do not well I have the
processes are very weird around
something that is a sensitive issue
obviously the United States driving is a
whole different thing
right yeah there's actually some some
would argue a much more strong process
around the driver's license
state-by-state yeah everyone should go
to Florida once in their life I think I
wonder
oh no way okay Hollywood Florida
Hollywood Florida we've left pretty
quickly but that's one of those places
where I look at my experience and I
realize not everyone that I've worked
with in my life grew up knowing how to
run away from alligators and seeing
Rockets go into outer space after school
and so maybe my imagination might be a
little bit more stretched little
different because my environment around
me was such but no it was a wonderful
wonderful time what's your most
controversial thought in the industry
whoa and if you don't say controversial
thought I'm gonna make you say one so
you have to say something that's
controversial women can do anything
that's that's not controversial oh okay
Oh in crypto what's your most
controversial thought so when you say
people are gonna be like ah she's fine
I think ledger Nana's font is too small
ledger nano is too small what the font
is too small you're alienating the use
case Oh boomers are left out of being
able to store their crypto securely now
that was an expert way to not answer the
question I appreciate it that's
controversial they haven't created a
larger version but they they won't uh I
don't think they're ever gonna change it
make a bigger option just
Brick buttons but I think that's their
point okay well do not have it be a big
I have to I have to click it for my dad
because he can't see those numbers
that's fair
I do appreciate when I'm on the subway
or just walking somewhere and you ever
see an older person and they have their
phone up there text messages zoomed in
it the text is just it's like what are
you reading all headlines like why do
you need the text down yeah but makes it
alright most important book you've ever
read the little book of economics by
Greg it what is that assume about
economics tiny tiny book and you can
finish in an easy afternoon for those
that don't read can't where you don't
like to read and it walks you through
how this world works and I think it's
something that we take for granted
understanding supply and demand and why
the markets exist and so highly
recommend this book you think you
understand crypto you have no background
in economics you have no background in
business you are not even interested in
that just read this book and I'll help
you just get a little bit of a sense of
why the world moves the way it does I
love it I always end but you asked me
one question but first aliens somebody
rightfully so guests on Twitter that I
asked you about aliens so here we are
real or not real obviously obviously
aisle obviously real but we can go down
in the path of you know farmer paradox
if we need just if we do think things
exist I think we do need to make space
to listen and we haven't and you can
translate that over to crypto we talk a
lot we barely listen to people so let's
all take quiet for a little bit and and
listen to our surroundings and do you
think that our inability to listen is
driven by technology or desire Oh desire
desire do you think we have the
technology available where we could
always we have the technology available
to listen but
do you think aliens have come here
before I'm here right no III do really
yeah
you think aliens have come to earth and
they've had contact him just somebody
hasn't told everyone because I don't
want to freak him out yeah I got like
denied a MetroCard and left left and
went back home my whole thing is just
it's I forget who said this on the
podcast and they really it's like stuck
with me they're like well just so we're
clear like in most instances in the
world where this one group of species
went and adopted the land of another
group of species it didn't work out so
well for the people who were originally
there right like maybe we don't want to
have contact yeah maybe we don't want
contact we do have Will Smith maybe we
already have contacted we just don't
know or maybe we're looking at this all
wrong and it's not what's in outer space
but what's under the sea that's been my
thing know how long is we know more
about Mars than we know about what's
under this I'd like to go there first
there's a I think he's Brazilian or
Russian billionaire I need to I need to
get this guy the podcast he has
personally funded the building of a
underwater vehicle which is a one-seater
that goes to the depths of the ocean I
think he's been to three or four of the
seven oceans the absolute deepest point
and he gets in the vehicle and does it
himself Branson
yes and I don't think there's been that
much reporting on like what he's seen
right and so to me why would he tell
anyone
well why hey man you went to the bottom
of like the Indian Ocean like what's
down there right is it just sand like at
the bottom of the mat yeah or some
critters that you've never seen and
never want to see exactly so we'll see
what one question you have for me oh I'm
sorry that's my law and order texts text
down what is the biggest distraction for
you and your
dynasty building the biggest distraction
honestly the people who say the positive
things on Twitter I should stop the
people who say the negative things I
love it like you're not helping this
world out I Love You Man no I respond I
usually just thanks hope you having a
great day like I love it I do love to
turn a hater into a lover that's a
significant so I used to say meant I
used to be like the end goal is to get
them to like see the light yeah
now I'm not that's not even my goal my
goal is literally just to let you know
like I read your nonsense just like you
know a little like or flame that ever
yeah I should actually start flaming the
haters that'd be a good one
maybe there's a gift where the guy's got
a flame threat I just started with like
I I hear you I see you you're too
empathetic I'm much more ignorant yeah I
think that the people who what I did not
realize 2 3 years ago is how the
tribalism the enthusiasm that all of
this stuff that makes crypto bitcoins
after what it is I think we all think of
like the the critical toxicity right I'd
recently interviewed somebody who made
an argument that like it's actually a
good thing right
yeah there's arguments that it's a bad
thing whatever tribes have helped
momentum occur with most movements yeah
I think that we see when we talk about
it we talk about it from a negative
connotation I think that the opposite is
true would there's a bunch of positive
and you can look and see I mean looks I
think I'll pick on cz for a second right
like he is the beneficiary of there's
much people who think very positively of
it right there's a cz tribe if you will
and that's not a bad thing he didn't ask
for that he just he did his job and
that's what happens I think that if you
asked him and a number of other people
in the industry if you just pay
attention to that like you very quickly
think you could walk on water right and
like it can very quickly become this
distraction of like you've achieved a
goal you've done something I think
what I've noticed is having the
detractors having the like hey we want
to do this deal but we lost the deal to
another investor and having to like go
back and fight for some allocation and
it's like these little daily reminders
if you're just like this is a really
really long game and like that random
you know Twitter account whether they're
saying positive or negative things then
really matter at the end of the day yeah
right and so I think people don't want
to listen to the quote-unquote trolls
when they're saying negative things but
want to prop themselves up mentally when
they're listening to the trolls say
positive things yeah so it's kind of
keeping a reminder that they're the same
yeah I still Ram
Twitter account that's that's true no
easy Suzy's modest humble hardcore
freedom so is that what it is that's
what it is
humble hardcore freedom I like that so
we like to go after that and you can do
it in sandals so he's killing it all
right thank you so much for doing this I
really appreciate it where can people go
to find by Nantz us to find you WWF
finance us finance dot us finance us
finance no calm no calm calm is a
another marketplace but somebody has
financed us calm no no someone has
financed calm oh yeah no it's just
finance us look around for us and then
you can find us on Twitter at finance
America you can find me on Twitter at
Krypto Kohli and you can join our
community telegram group driven by the
community for the community and then you
can also follow our announcements on the
website also by other than that
get ready humble hardcore freedom it's
happening all right thank you so much
thanks so much guys hey everyone
pop here if you like this episode of off
the chain and want to help us to take
crypto to the top of the Apple Spotify
and other podcast charts please do us a
favor and rate review and subscribe to
review simply go to the off-the-chain
homepage scroll down until you see the
five blank stars taking 15 seconds to
fill those stars in and leave a quick
review goes a long way in helping us
take the entire crypto ecosystem to the
top of the charts I appreciate you
listening and see you next time on off
the chain